[Music]  making a very revenge wave Robert  husband  it tears and the soul where's your  brother now but it can also be a weapon  he  I'm done with running and I'm sick of  hating how ice making decisions and  whatever course you are charting I  choose you my husband  we need a United scope honor Robert the  Bruce is enough for any man or woman who  would give shelter to him or his ranks  is to be executed without trial the  people are desperate for justice I serve  Robert Bruce join our free  [Applause]  how fifty men to fight the strongest  this is how we do it  take the Lombok castle by castle  we could fight for God  [Music]  but coke drink  but funnily  I do not care  so long as you  you  you